dianna d mascara isn't afraid to speak
truth to power or failing that to just
kick power's ass warner media unveiled
new footage for the upcoming Wonderwoman
1984 at their HBO max presentation this
week and it features Gaga nuts Diana
engaged in a brawl in an unlikely place
inside the White House the promotion
machine for the sequel to the 2017 smash
hit Wonder Woman is finally starting to
kick into gear and well it doesn't look
like the new footage is going to be
released online we have a detailed
breakdown thanks to the folks at IGN the
footage heavily features Chris Pine
Steve Trevor whom you may remember
appeared to be quite dead at the
conclusion of the first film it's
unclear how he'll return especially
considering the nearly four decade time
jump between the two movies diana may be
a virtually ageless quasi goddess but
when it comes to trevor the filmmakers
will have some pretty heavy narrative
lifting to do in explaining his apparent
resurrection and failure to age perhaps
they'll steal a page from the classic
70's and 80's Wonder Woman television
series when it jumped time periods from
the 40s to the 70s the presence of
Trevor portrayed by the same actor was
hand waved with the explanation that 70s
Trevor was actually the original guy's
son who looked identical to his father
right down to the haircut sure why not
at any rate the new footage opens with a
shot of Trevor and Diana strolling along
the Washington Monument what Diana
wearing the type of flowy white dress
that one might expect to see on Themis
Keira but not necessarily in Washington
DC and voiceover she says the line of
dialogue I can almost see it like a
beautiful dream as she caresses Steve's
face in the next scene Trevor and Diana
are seen under attack from gun wielding
assailants in the halls of the White
House which doesn't sound like a
beautiful dream at all like we said we
don't actually have access to this
footage but it may look a little
something like the last time a superhero
took on the White House and the second
x-men movie it might also look a little
bit like this just use your imagination
in the actual footage diana is wearing
that crazy new armor that was teased in
a promotional one-sheet back in June and
she has her hands full protecting Trevor
from incoming gunfire while taking down
baddies the clip briefly moves to slow
motion as Diana snatches away an
attackers gun and deftly unloads it then
she brings her lasso into play roping
as in and pulling them towards her so
she can deliver finishing blows in a
maneuver that would make Mortal Kombat
scorpion proud the clip ends is Diana
uses her lasso to deflect a bolt of
energy from an unseen opponent the
footage reveals that Diana will be
facing down some powerful enemies both
in terms of political power and found
freaky energy poults unfortunately it
doesn't clue us in as to the deal with
trevor so we'll just go ahead and guess
that he somehow survived his plane
blowing up at a high altitude then went
on to invent the most amazing
anti-wrinkle cream the world has ever
seen so far only a precious few people
have gotten to actually see this footage
from the movie as no trailer for the
sequel has yet been released however
thanks to director patty Jenkins
spilling the beans we now know when that
will happen on December 8th that the
Comic Con experience at South Paulo
Brazil the flicks panel will close out
the event which will be live streamed to
be its official Twitter page although it
hasn't been officially confirmed it's
assumed that the CC XP spot will drop
online shortly thereafter fans have been
waiting a long time and principal
photography on the film wrapped about a
year ago so we can probably expect a
pretty beefy first trailer
hopefully a bit of the mystery
surrounding the plot of Wonder Woman
1984 will be cleared up when the trailer
drops next month the first film's
director patty Jenkins also held this
installment working from a script she
co-wrote with shang-chi and the legends
of the ten ring scribe Dave Callahan and
comics writer Jeff jobs in addition to
gal gadot and Chris Pine the cast
includes Connie Nielsen and Robin
Wright's reprising their roles as
hipolito and anti Opie respectfully
joining Wonder Woman newcomers Pedro
Pascal as Maxwell Lord and Kristen Wiig
is Barbara Minerva aka cheetah or
Gabriella wild Ravi Patel and Natasha
Rothwell the movie hits the big screen
on June 5th 2020 check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]